[Music]
[Music]
rockstar has released a meaty six-minute
gameplay trailer for Red Dead Redemption
- there's a lot to unpack here like the
gorgeous open world impressive attention
to detail and some of the various new
mechanics however I'm most curious about
how the player will interact with the
world based on the gameplay trailer
Rockstar is trying to change it up
partially through NPC interactions and
the video the narrator says your guns
aren't the only way to interact with the
environment this may seem small compared
to everything else the trailer shows but
if done correctly this has the potential
to shake up the open-world formula
[Music]
for the longest time especially in
sandbox action games like GTA and
assassin's creed non-player characters
apart from being set dressings seem to
have two responses to the player
friendly or violent if they are friendly
they will either stay out of your way or
offer you a mission and if they are
agitated they will probably try to kill
you today these binary NPC responses
have gotten predictable if you see some
people with guns or swords drawn it
probably means you should ready yourself
up for a fight in the video Rockstar
claims that you will be able to
contextually defuse or escalate
confrontations threaten witnesses and
reason with a town sheriff this could
make every random interaction or
encounter feel dynamic and carry more
consequences picture this you ride into
a small dusty town you are low on
resources and money so you decide to rob
a warehouse while rummaging through the
stuff in the building the owner walks in
and spots you without skipping a beat he
runs for the town sheriff you can stop
him before he gets to the sheriff by
putting a bullet in his back or tackling
him to the ground and threatening him or
maybe you're too slow and before you can
catch him he's already informed the
sheriff the sheriff confronts you do you
retaliate and kill the sheriff knowing
that the whole town could erupt in
gunfire or do you back down although
this is a hypothetical situation this
level of interaction has a ton of
potential and it begs the question what
type of outlaw will you be once and for
all we don't know much about Arthur
Morgan's character arc but this system
gives the player the potential to shape
who Arthur Morgan is you could be a cold
unforgiving outlaw or a cunning cowboy
with a silver tongue Rockstar hasn't
talked about whether or not your actions
will have far-reaching consequences but
giving the player the freedom to react
to these situations as they see fit is
enticing you aren't locked into a
firefight just because you picked a
fight with a bar patron or trampled
someone with a horse
speaking of your horse these dynamic
interactions will extend to your steed
different breeds will have different
attributes and personalities some breeds
may not do well with water while others
might scare easily you can grow your
bond with your horse by feeding it
grooming it and calming it they're
stronger the bond with your horse is the
easier it will be to calm once again
this may seem small but it could add
another level of depth and believability
to the world characters and animals you
come across seem like more than just set
dressing you can trick them threaten
them agitate them and react to them as
you please it's hard to say just how
in-depth this feature will be when the
game releases on October 26th but we'll
be sure to let you know if we find out
more
[Music]